I think Bitcoin is a fundamental
reimagining of human civilization it's
only through consensual Exchange in a
bitcoinized world that we are productive
its Integrity is rooted in the laws of
physics and it's resistant to politics
because it's dematerialized Bitcoin
optimizes our ability to express our
worlds of power and therefore lets us be
free all right guys bang bang I've got
Robert here with me I thought a great
place that we could start the
conversation is money is a proxy for
power this is one of the big Ideas I
think that you've been thinking a lot
about and talking about what does that
mean money is a proxy for power yeah
um yeah I guess I should first probably
give a shout out to people that have
helped me form these ideas
um
you know Sailors been very no noteworthy
for bringing this energy element into
the discussion of money
um before him I was really focused on
the time aspect and then people like
Lowry started to bring this power
projection thesis to the foreground
and when I really started to dissect
that and you look at Power through the
lens of physics there's a formula for
power actually and it it has components
of both energy and time so
I'm hoping that this framing is a little
bit more useful in telling about the
nature and history of money
and then it also but to get there we
have to kind of decompose power itself
and start to Define it
um in my opinion you know most people I
think today when we say power
they think it's just like arbitrary
political like I'm your boss or I'm your
state Statesman something like that I
can tell you what to do my willpower is
superordinate over yours but that's all
of this political power that we create
in our imaginations there's this other
form of power that's very important
which is physical power and
um
you know so money I guess this is
somewhat obvious like if we talk about
money in terms of purchasing power which
is what we ultimately want you don't
want
whether you know it or not you don't
want a number of dollars in your bank
account you what you actually desire is
the purchasing power that money provides
to you yes so when we talk about
inflation being the diminishing of the
purchasing power per unit
um that's why prices go up et cetera et
cetera so there's a there's a parasitic
relationship occurring in fiat currency
where producers of that currency are
basically siphoning power off of those
that use it and saving it
um so this isn't like an original idea
really like again if you just what you
want in money is purchasing power so
money is a proxy for power but then it
gets interesting I think when we break
it down into
how it relates to the physical dimension
of power versus the political Dimension
okay talk about the physical one first
what does it mean the physical dimension
of power yeah so I think the first you
know when we start these deep
conversations we need to back up a
little bit first so first thing to
understand is that humans are animals
right we we are participating in this
darwinian process of survival
um I like to say that you know we are
basically genetic information
encoded for survival or programmed for
survival through eons of evolution
adapted to our surroundings to survive
so we are this message if you will
propagating Through Blood flesh bone Etc
and
and that way all life forms it's not
just humans obviously all life forms are
basically these survival strategies
propagating through organisms
and I think this is honestly this is a
good through line too because your your
organs individually have their own
Survival strategy they've specialized if
you will in this economy of your body
the organism itself is a a macro
representation of that and then even
organizations that we create in the
world they behave like organisms right
they have life cycles They Live and Die
in terms of economics they have to have
more inflows and outflows just like you
have to eat more calories than you
expend otherwise you die so this is
these are all systems of energy or power
and that like we were talking about the
Italian Prime Minister video earlier
that just aired and she had this great
line in there where she said something
to the the effect of each of our genetic
code is unique non-repeatable and
therefore sacred yes it's like yes
that's what we're doing like and if you
you have kids I have kids you know what
it's like to be a parent like mother
nature sort of flips a dial inside of
you it's not something that is really
within our control at all like we are
part of nature rather than just
controlling nature
um and so in that sense I think you know
Nietzsche is famous for his his will to
power quote and I think he's right
honestly but he has you have to
understand power
through the physics sense and so I'll
read his quote real quick Niche wrote
even the body within which individuals
treat each other as equals will have to
be an incarnate Will To Power it will
strive to grow spread seize become
predominant not from any morality or
immorality but because it is living and
because life simply is Will To Power so
what we're doing right now like to
breathe to speak to think to talk to
move these are all expressions of a Will
To Power because
well to Define power in the physics
sense it's ultimately just to move
Energy across time so it's the capacity
to move that's what power is in a purely
physic sense and
to get into the formula
physics is power equals work divided by
time
um
work so I have to decompose that formula
further now work equals force times
displacement which basically means a
force applied across space so what do we
do when we combine that you basically
get power equals
Force time space divided by time that
sounds ridiculous but what it basically
means is
power is just the capacity for movement
yeah right that's what we're doing here
that's what we're doing in economics is
we're trying to increase the amount of
Natural Resources we can mobilize and
bend to our will to further our our
wants in the world to satisfy more human
wants yeah it reminds me of two things
one is like weapons of war is who can
move uh analog physical assets yes
faster larger create more destruction
right all these things so if you think
of a bullet is basically the ability to
project power at a speed and in a very
concentrated surface area to penetrate
uh whether it's armor a human body
whatever the other thing is things like
an RPG in the most General sense
basically are able to puncture armor and
then insert a grenade you know like uh
object to then explode right which is
another kind of secondary uh use of
power so like the weapons of war is very
obvious but also if you think of a
corporation which really is one of the
key foundations of the Industrial
Revolution and the ability to organize
resources and people and capital and all
these things it was done not because
people sat around I was like let's
create more bureaucracy like oh we're
unorganized it was done because there
was leverage to create more Force more
movement and the ability ability to
increase output yes right and so in both
of those situations you are creating
output one is for an economic uh agenda
the other is for kind of a geopolitical
or a war agenda yes but it is all output
that's a great great example actually
and
obviously closely related are the
weapons of war and the political power
structures and I like the example of the
corporation too because that is an
imaginal structure right we fabricated
that in the imagination of ourselves and
we
we implement it into the collective
imagination if you will and I'll expand
on what more of this means as we go but
but that's I guess the key point so far
is that it grounds out in physics right
as reality grounds out in physics if
you're not moving breathing talking
you're not alive right you're not
relevant to this socioeconomic game
we're all playing with each other
so
in economics you know the entire point
is to increase the division of labor and
we talked about this last time on a
previous episode but basically there's a
physical principle that human beings
accomplish more working in cooperatively
rather than they do in isolation and so
if that was not true we would not trade
with one another yes right it's not like
we just decided to do this out of the
kindness of our hearts it's it's a very
pragmatic uh mode of being let's say
another kind of point to this which I
think is uh very interesting there's a
book that I recent read called the rise
and fall of American growth and talks
all about 1870 to 1970 and it completely
changed the way that I looked at so many
different things but one of the key
Concepts uh was pretty much 1870 to like
1900 1920 somewhere in there uh every
single home was essentially an
individual node they were what they
called unnetworked so they were not
connected when it came to electricity
when it came to uh sewage and uh water
and like all these different things and
it basically had to operate in a way
where you said you have humans who live
inside of this home they have to get
water and food and power and you know
all these different components and the
people in that home went out into the
world every day and did the things
necessary to be able to do that and so
you know it was something like 75 of all
people who lived at that time uh ended
up doing jobs that were undesirable uh a
very large portion of them were farmers
and they operated off of the land like
all this stuff by the time you get to
for sure 1970 but even as early as like
1920 those homes now had you know four
or five different components they now
were networked for electricity they were
networked for water they were networked
for all these different things and so in
some way uh while we think of individual
versus a group from a productivity
standpoint also on a societal standpoint
if everyone was siled in a single home
on and they had to live off the land
there's production that happens right
but damn is it powerful when you put all
these folks together in a network and
they work on okay you're going to be the
power our company right right you make
sure we all have power yes somebody else
you're going to be the water company
right and and it ends up bringing people
together in a really unique way that
ends up increasing economic output 100
we what did uh biology said this at the
conference yesterday many Apes strong a
line from uh Planet of the Apes I think
so when we cooperate especially when we
cooperate intelligently right like you
specialize in this I'll specialize in
that well each honor one another's
property rights and will trade that's
what increases the division of labor and
allows us to accomplish way more than
the sum of our parts yes so and that's
the whole that's why we Tinker that's
why we innovate that's why we trade is
to achieve greater results with less
efforts that is equivalent to wealth
right we can do more satisfy more wants
enjoy more of a luxurious lifestyle
ultimately because let's face it we live
in absolute luxury compared to people
100 years ago or 200 years ago and that
is
you know there's a lot of problems to
solve in the world but if you can solve
that one that at least creates the
freedom for people to go and address
other problems so I think it's the most
fundamental thing we should try and
address as a species so
to do that and this is among the
defining features of humanity we use
open source Technologies largely to
contribute to that
language mathematics even money as we've
talked about before like gold I would
argue is kind of an analog open source
technology everyone could see how it
works no one could do anything about it
so it you know took over the world for a
number of reasons but all of these are
designed to optimize our coordination
and there's a great term from a guy I
talked to named John bravecki he calls
these psycho Technologies okay so
whereas a technology like a physical
technology increases our fitness to the
world our fitness to purpose somehow
psycho technology is just something that
enhances our cognitive Fitness to the
world so the fact that I can make these
sounds with my mouth right now and you
know what I'm saying like it's because
we're both users of this open source
technology called English yes and
so that is very fundamental to creating
that division of labor that creates all
this wealth and allows us to engage in
the process of civilization
so
Technologies psycho Technologies all
really important to human flourishing
but I think the key a key point that and
this is where I hope this conversation
is a little bit unique these things are
all born in the human imagination yes we
always
forget to stop and consider that yes and
when you start to have this lens on the
world when I walk around downtown Miami
and I'm looking at all these you know
high rises and cars and all the software
people are using I'm just it can get
almost overwhelming like all of this was
just born in someone's imagination and
then well many people's imaginations
over time and you they go in and print
that imagination into physical reality
to create all this stuff so it's a very
key component to all of this we're
talking about
and that says so we said humans are
animals but humans are different because
humans are animals with very
sophisticated imaginations yes so we
create these tools to increase our
fitness to each other uh and to the
world and again if you have kids this is
sort of obvious I have to thank my
daughter for inspiring a lot of this
they grow up just plain imaginary
non-stop right yes non-stop like new new
outfit new role new name you're this
you're that here's my stuffed animal
that's named this and then we just think
kids stop doing that arbitrarily
somewhere like in teenage years no we
don't stop at all
we're doing it right now all right like
you run a business several businesses
those are all imaginal structures right
people
ain't willingly engage in those
hierarchies and assume a role in that
structure but it's all imaginal right
the authority that the boss projects
over the employee like it's they've
connected their imaginations together in
this Enterprise called the business and
that's what we do that's how we run the
world is because we engage with the our
imaginal realities to reshape physical
realities in a very sophisticated way I
think a lot about real estate like
commercial real estate so
um there is a couple blocks from here
huge uh uh entire block of grass and
it's kind of in a weird part because
it's in downtown but it's grass there's
nothing there and so uh I've walked by
it hundreds of times and what I said to
myself like somebody's gonna do
something with that somebody's gonna do
something with that right something
could be a strip mall could be a
high-rise like there's a bunch of
different things that you could do so we
could build a parking deck there right
whatever it is recently it was announced
that they are going to uh create a very
large high-rise building that's
residential with restaurants and all
stuff well when they make that
announcement uh they say who's going to
do it and what do they do they publicize
the renderings of what is going to be
there and so somebody sat down and Drew
this is what we could do and they
socialized it with the group and the
group was like that looks awesome we
should do that people want to live there
that will create economic activity the
numbers work like all of these other
things started to follow
but it's not very different than a young
kid sitting down saying like look at
this house I drew 100 right and what
becomes fascinating is and I think that
this was uh maybe one of the Carlson
Brothers at stripe or somebody I saw
tweet and was like you forget when you
walk around that things that exist in
the world buildings businesses cars all
stuff
somebody had to have the idea somebody
had to have the conviction and the
courage to go try to build it and then
somebody had to operationalize it to
actually say yes it's possible to build
a car but what if we built tens of
thousands of cars every single year what
if we were able to actually create lots
of concrete what if we were able to
create elevators what if we were able to
use glass for Windows and and do all
this stuff
and it sounds so stupid because you're
like yeah guys duh like there's
buildings but if you really kind of draw
it back it's like human imagination in
some way is the same thing like oxygen
to the human body oh interesting right
without the imagination you don't really
have a society there's no civilization
yeah that you all you have is just
straight up I kill you you kill me I
need food for my family the imagination
is what gives order organization uh and
ultimately economic productivity
super well said
um yeah we're fighting against you know
nature gives us plenty of uncertainty to
deal with and the imagination is our
greatest defense or weapon against that
let's see
and I don't know if that's the same
tweet you're referring to but someone
referred to
the entire world is a museum of passion
projects so when you see all of these
buildings and businesses and ideas and
games everything everything that humans
create right starts here and then
through a whole lot of work and
perseverance
sometimes if it's successful gets
imprinted into the real world and then
we just like plug into these realities
and take them for granted in a lot of
ways but it's easy to forget how much it
took to get to this point so
I guess the point is
most people think kids stop playing
imagineer at some point but I would say
if you've got a job if you use money if
you're a citizen of a country then you
are engaged in serious imaginal play
whether you understand it or not yep and
I would say if you don't understand it
actually you're more likely to be
possessed by one of those structures
rather than if you understand how this
works you can just be a voluntary
participant let's say
and so I want to
call these something I want to call
these imaginal structures we often call
them hierarchies you could call them
social institutions you call them
imaginal structures
um Yuval Harare and his book sapiens I
think called these the imagined orders
I today I'm just so all these terms I'm
going to use the term symbolic structure
okay so language is symbolic right we're
using code to communicate and then when
we press all those ideas together and
then push them into the physical world
when we press them together we create a
symbolic structure that gets pushed in
the physical world to become a
skyscraper or become a battleship or
whatever it is
so
your company money nation states these
are all symbolic structures that we
inhabit in this imaginal space
um so we're we're storytellers right
that's what we're saying here these are
just stories it's like Jordan Peterson
always talks about we live in stories
first time I heard that I was like that
sounds ridiculous
course everything's a story because
everything's a description of a sequence
of events but that's not I don't think
that's what he meant he meant something
more like this that we're creating these
imagined realities and then we inhabit
them like as in as a member of society
let's say
Plato has a great quote he said those
who tell stories rule Society
this is [ __ ] Plato right like he got
this he very brilliant guy there's
another quote that someone said this
reminded them of uh when I posted this
on Twitter they said who controls the
past Now controls the future
who controls the present Now controls
the past
so in these very deep but very true yes
in these symbolic structures
you know we heard this quote history is
written by the winners
it's very often that the symbolic
structure
gets written or Rewritten by the winner
uh in the the domain of the physical
right so physical Warfare if a new
country
undergoes a revolution and a new leader
is installed they'll typically go
straight to work rewriting history all
right if you go to North Korea today
there's all these statues deifying Kim
whatever his name Kim Jong-un so he's
that's how he is dominating the symbolic
structure of North Korea is by deifying
himself as part of it I think it's even
I believe it uh you have to have a photo
of him in your home
so it's not just like the public you
know uh I would say uh Open Spaces I
don't know how open they are yeah um but
like literally in your own home you have
to have a photo of them that's crazy
um
but and so the Yuval Harare thing in
sapiens his whole punch line started to
ruin the book If you haven't read it
human beings are the animal that can
cooperate flexibly in large numbers
there's many species that can cooperate
flexibly
um
uh example escapation here there's many
that can cooperate in large numbers like
bees but they can't the way he puts it
is only human you can only unite 10 000
human beings on a battlefield under a
flag
so whereas all these other animals are
subject to the Dunbar number or
something equivalent for their species
human beings or not we can combine our
forces in a way that no other animal can
and that's the reason we're the top of
the food chain basically and so I think
this is points to to why the struggle
has always been for the collective human
imagination right religion propaganda
even Modern Nation statism where it's
much more energy efficient to get people
to subscribe to your symbolic structure
than it is to force it on them yes
because if you force it on them they're
gonna you know cut Corners backstab you
at every chance you can get and we know
this we know this intuitively so the
um the game I guess is to try and be
influential right and so
I want to focus on we could talk about
that for a long time because there's a
lot of history there but I want to focus
on the nation state because that's the
one we live in today all right this is
the dominant symbolic structure in the
world
and
I'm here as you were there yesterday to
attend uh an event talking about the
network state which is this
let's say embryonic idea for the future
of nation states and there was a small
gathering here in Miami and a lot of
really interesting ideas thrown around
um and one was shared with me that you
could actually decompose
nation state into nation and state
sounds pretty obvious but the nation is
more
uh the root word of nation is natality I
want to say and this relates to like
NATO so like the birth and growth of a
people so this is going to refer to the
people the culture the wisdom Traditions
uh the modes of being
Etc the state though is the like
administrative layer or the political
apparatus within that area that's really
there it's a monopoly on violence that
exists to resolve disputes
over uh
resolve disputes of people over scarce
resources so another way to say that is
the state exists to preserve the
relationship between people and their
stuff so if you create something of
value and someone tries to take that
from you
recourse to the state is how you resolve
that so we've outsourced the defense of
our property effectively
and
at its best a nation-state
world's political power and I'm going to
get into what political power means
shortly
to defend the market process from
Interruption so you want people to be
maximally free and to be maximally free
you need strong property right you need
an Integrity of the relationship between
you and your stuff so that you can
engage in the process of a consensual
exchange increase the division of labor
increase wealth and therefore increase
the collective physical power harnessed
by human beings in the marketplace
right so it's this
and we talk as we talked about last time
I framed this as useful ideas a lot and
so it's kind of the same thing it's more
useful ideas are implemented whether
it's property whether it's an iPhone or
a laptop these are just better ideas for
communicating or accomplishing human
purpose
that gives you more movement more wealth
creation so that's what the state acts
as like this insulating layer to prevent
that from being attacked
but we've been trapped in this situation
with the state for a long time that it
tends to start to prey on the very thing
it's supposed to protect over time which
has been a real problem when you start
to kind of unpack uh the division of
labor and a lot of these pieces
it feels like the sum of it the parts
are more valuable than than individually
but also when you then overlay things
like property rights
you then are able to do something very
different because actually property
rights usually are thought of as defense
so you cannot take my property
but in some way it's also a uh Tailwind
to give people more conviction to
specialize yes so when you think of the
farm why did you have the ability to get
water food and all the things you needed
for you and your family to survive
because you had no confidence that
anyone else was coming to save you right
now when you move to modern society
I don't think that I know very many
people who have a farm because they have
greater confidence that the food supply
whether you like it or not or think it's
good or could be improved or whatever
will provide food and so they have the
confidence to not have to go spend time
on farming because they say somebody
else in our society has taken on that
division of labor and I am going to go
specialize in whatever whether it's a
white collar job a blue collar job or
anything in between
and so property rights not only protect
what you're doing but it gives you the
confidence to become more and more and
more specialized
and still have the safety net of society
that says yes food will be at the
grocery store yes
whether you have property rights or not
if at any point your confidence that
food will be at the grocery store or
clean water is going to be there or any
of these things that you don't
specialize in if that ever breaks down
that's when all hell breaks loose and we
return back to a world
where no one had confidence and they had
to be self-sufficient and there's just
not a lot of people that are prepared to
do that yes today's episode is brought
to you by ftxus they're a safe regulated
way to buy Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
they've got very cheap fees sometimes as
much as 85 percent cheaper than their
competitors there's also no minimum fees
there's no withdrawal fees or any other
hidden fees ultimately FTX us is trying
to make it dead simple for you to buy
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they also
now have digital stock trading as well
no transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the FTX app today from the App
Store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again Go download the
FTX app today use code pop and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the FTX app today yeah
that would be the collapse of the
division of labor yes collapse of wealth
creation which is equivalent to the
collapse of civilization yes so like I
hammer this point so hard people's
wealth is demonized a lot wealth is
should not be demonized it's the basis
of the solution to most problems I would
argue and I think that point you made it
so good because what does that mean
right confidence in property rights that
means other people are engaging in the
symbolic structure playing this imaginal
game with you and it's the confidence
you have that they'll continue to honor
the rules of the game as will you now if
confidence is shaken for any reason it
it unwinds the whole thing the whole
thing goes involuted if you really think
about uh laws right
and you were to Overlay it with the
imaginary game that kids play the
changing of a law is no different than
the five kids out in the backyard being
like okay now uh that used to be out of
bounds now it's not out of bounds
anymore and then people start running
over there and the game continues like
that is the exact equivalent of
legislation and laws like all these
things that grown-ups are playing yes
but also uh laws in human nature uh
or sometimes at odds yes
but the beauty of good laws is that it
is able to use human nature as uh and
align those incentives so that humans
will do what humans are going to do uh
but do it within some agreed upon uh
framework yes and so
you know I always go back to like if
there was no laws would most people go
out in the streets and start killing
people probably not right
but if there was no food in the city
and families were going hungry
doesn't matter if there's laws or not
at some point right I think there's a
saying like uh you really see what a man
is capable of if uh if he doesn't eat
for three days yeah right right and so
it's almost like the laws have to align
with the human nature because you can't
have people like the laws don't matter
if people are hungry yeah the laws don't
matter if people feel like uh their
life's in danger yeah and you actually
see this in society like thou shall not
kill is written into law Yes except for
if he's gonna kill you
then you can you know I mean like it's a
very weird way to look at it but in some
way the law and human nature do have to
align or therefore Society eventually
rejects the law 100 so much good stuff
there um
Peterson again
this idea that
well you just said
thou shall not kill is written directly
into the law
there's a mythological substructure to
Western civilization a lot of it is the
judeo-christian mythology right we would
not have gotten to property rights if we
did not have thou shall not kill in our
history like that's another important
it's a it's almost like the blockchain
of the imaginal structure right it's
building in layers over time we didn't
just decide out of the blue that we're
going to create the United States I mean
read the Federalist Peppers papers these
guys were Die Hard Christian or at least
inspired by the Bible to a large extent
and what you said too like good laws map
onto good incentives and I would argue
that people don't really follow laws
actually people follow incentives right
now if there's a if there's a credible
threat of force behind a law and that's
a disincentive to break it so you might
follow it for some period of time but
ultimately people are going to bend to
their own incentives
and the point with the kids the kids hey
that's out of bounds now that's out of
bounds what do you think we're doing
with national borders yes we're that's
it this is this is your country this is
my country and there's layers to it like
there's National borders but even if you
think of like voting districts like
that's the one that always cracks me up
right is that like you ever seen them
drawn and it looks like a square and
then in one corner it like reaches out
and grabs like a city right and comes
back and you're like if I was just to
come up with a random voting City or
voting district that's not the shape
that I would draw right now it may be
for good reason or bad reason or
whatever right people love to debate
that stuff but like that is the drawing
of imaginary lines that then feed into a
game that is around voting yes that then
dictates who gets to play What role in
the game Who benefits from the proceeds
stolen from Taxation and inflation
that's what that game is right you get
voted in office and then you get to
decide what to do with the stolen booty
um so again we needed to play that game
because we needed to
create Integrity of relationship between
people and their stuff in the physical
world
but the problem with that game is that
monopolist on violence a security
provider over time has tended to start
to bend the rules to their own favor the
individuals that come into power inside
of the state have tended to corrupt the
state and we'll get into Corruption of
it later but
and and I also think a key piece is
that's part of the division of labor
which people tend to forget of like if
you go back 200 years like guess who
protected your home you better right
right because if you didn't or you and
your you know equivalent of a
neighborhood did not you were [ __ ] yes
and so at some point the farmer said
okay this other person is going to be
the farmer and you're going to provide
food for the village and this other
person is going to provide the security
this other person is going to provide
you know whatever uh the horses or or
whatever the division of labor ended up
being
but you had to have the confidence not
only in the property rights and all this
but they would do their job yeah because
uh the fastest way for people to get
really interested in self-defense is to
look had a group of people and say you
can't protect me yeah right and and you
see this actually the place where
unfortunately we see it is look at
natural disasters natural disasters come
in and it breaks down so many of the
agreed upon uh kind of structures of a
society and so if you go back to
Hurricane Katrina and uh um maybe a
decade ago or so now uh I remember that
there was uh the National Guard was
being called in and literally you had
armed National Guard men uh and women
who were patrolling Walmart
yeah because Walmart was selling their
physical goods and they were keeping the
money in the back because there was no
armored trucks to come pick it up right
like you start to say okay hold on a
second
did Walmart call did an individual in
the community did the governor like I
don't know how it happened but
the reason why we don't have armed
soldiers in every single store is
because there's a general belief that
the local police the security systems
the technology all this stuff can
protect
the goods and the store owner yes when
that breaks down
it goes back to get armed men here 100
100 that's a great example where
Hurricane Katrina was kind of like a
real dose of physical power totally
obliterating all of these symbolic
structures a lot of them premised on I
never thought of it that way yeah and
then as you said the armed guards they
coalesce around the money right that's
being taken in so political power
coalesces to the physical power that
money represents in in some way you
could actually argue uh does Society put
more value on human life or on the money
and if the armed guards or the help come
into an area and they go and they
protect the money yeah
it opens up a lot of questions yes right
and and thankfully it's not binary right
it's not like hey there's only one
person which way do they go it's a fork
in the road because at the same time we
had helicopters flying in and rescuing
people off of roofs and and doing all of
these like heroic actions where uh it
was obvious that some value was being
placed on the life but it does start to
open up the Nuance of a conversation
that's like very interesting to think
about 100 uh
I was actually there for a mission trip
after like a I guess it was nine months
maybe after okay and Bay St Louis were
the eye of the hurricane Hut did you
know the Canadian mounties made it there
before the U.S national guard I did not
know that yeah that is crazy so on their
horses uh I don't know if they were on
horses but they made it down there yeah
um so there's symbolic structure right
was actually being more faithful to the
people of this country at that time
which I thought was shocking
um and then this one other point on the
Walmart thing
had that been Bitcoin though and the
money was dematerialized you would have
there would not be a need to defend the
property in a physical way assuming you
custody it properly so I'm kind of
foreshadowing what we're going to talk
about later but
the physicality of money is what leads
to the relevance of political power and
force let's say in the physical world
and and the value of of human life
versus monetary energy
you know I would argue again there's the
through line there of power right I
guess people are a Will To Power they're
alive they're they're useful to other
people they can perform labor they have
ideas we can think we can talk right we
have humans are amazing the most amazing
asset we have frankly Is Us
um and so to the extent that
you can defend that right to protect the
sanctity of the individual or that
sacred genetic code as the Italian Prime
Minister said earlier that's
that's the whole game here absolutely
um Okay so
a bit of a segue but just on the
emergence of the nation state itself
it emerges as a result of the
industrialization of military technology
right there's a reason World War one and
World War II were of such a scope scale
and severity that the world had never
seen before
those reasons were the mechanization and
industrialization of War fighting
equipment
um and I would also insert fiat currency
here that these governments were not on
a gold standard right so they would
suspend redeemability for gold start
printing money to finance the war up to
the point of hyperinflating the currency
um and then that has follow-on negative
consequences when you consider Hitler
was born From the Ashes of the Weimar
hyperinflation right currency collapse
people when the currency collapses
people go crazy the whole world breaks
down the entire symbolic structure
collapses let's say and there becomes
this rousing demand for strong
leadership Law and Order
and that's what led to Hitler so
without getting too much into the
details uh many people I think uh know
the high level Hitler and uh kind of
somewhat of the rise to power and then
his uh attempted uh and thankfully uh
ultimate failure to take over much
larger areas of geographic land
um but there's some scary Nuance as you
learn more and more about that situation
where even in American politics there
was a lot of people who were very
supportive of Hitler for a very long
time yeah and part of it was because
there was this great fear of Russia and
so a little bit of the your enemy uh my
enemy's enemy is my friend uh and then
there was a long kind of this journey or
timeline certain actions that Hitler and
and uh kind of his whole crew took that
then was the Tipping Point okay fine now
I don't like it okay now I'm worried
okay now there's a threat
but it's not like uh to your point
that's a bad person they have no power
they have no organization they have no
weapons they have no anything and we
know that's a bad person
it's a lot different right it's a much
more con uh complex story
Osama Bin Laden is very similar in that
the enemy of my enemy is my friend
maybe we should help that person defeat
our enemy
and then the power consolidates and and
the weaponry and the training and all
these things the next thing you know
it's like oh wait a second like actually
maybe the Ally is the enemy yes and it
becomes this weird thing and it's a
story as old as time over and over and
over and over again but it does it is
worth learning about for people to
understand 100 and it follows the wealth
right it follows the money so the reason
so much gold ended up in North America
prior to the end of World War II during
World War II was because Hitler would
invade a country and he would plunder
the central bank's gold Supply
so enough countries had seen this happen
they started sending their gold across
the Atlantic
so when enough gold ended up in North
America at a certain point we were very
reticent to enter the war for a long
time but at a certain point it was like
well we got all the gold
there's been enough Devastation over
there we could probably just go clean it
up declare ourselves the Victor rewrite
the global banking rules of the Bretton
Woods conference and then B the global
dollar hegemony yes which indeed we did
and have been since 1944.
and so it's funny how it doesn't read
that way in the history books it's funny
how it's been Rewritten by the winner
right
and it also uh uh simple things at the
time how fast did the ships go yeah
right and and I think today people are
are so removed from a lot of this that
we don't think like oh who has the
faster fighter jet or who has the better
technology like that competition still
happens to uh to a great degree but at
the time like the difference between 24
or 30 knots literally could determine
yeah yeah and still about power right
yes
energy channeled across time the faster
you can Channel it the more effective
you are as a combatant or as an
entrepreneur even right if you can move
people in a plane faster than you can
move them in a car then people are going
to prefer planes to cars obviously so
the nation state is built on gold as we
just said about the United States and
for reasons we talked about in our last
episode together gold was already
selected by the free market as money
right it best satisfied the five
properties of money
but Chief among those qualities that
make gold good money is its scarcity
which was protected by the proof of work
necessary to mine well discover mine
extract refine gold and use it as money
and so that and this is the same thing
that maps onto Bitcoin it's that
expenditure of energy necessary to
produce gold as it is to produce Bitcoin
that secures the supply from
counterfeiting
and as I've said a lot inflation and
counterfeiting are the same thing all
right the central bank is a Global
Currency counterfeiting operation that's
all it is it doesn't add any value it's
parasitical on the market economy
that when you when you break like fiat
currency has zero proof of work
effectively that's why it gets produced
at infinitum and leads to World War One
World War II Global debt to GDP at 350
Etc
but I don't want to dwell on that I'm
going to stay on the power track here
proof of work basically means you need
to expend energy to acquire the value of
the money
right you need to expend power to
acquire the purchasing power let's say
um and this basically means you're
you're protected from political power if
you hold gold there's no political
institution in the world that can
arbitrarily say gold is not money
anymore and that's really important
especially in a world where Russian
Central Bank Reserves are being seized
at the tune of 600 billion dollars
Canadian truck protesters are having
their assets seized for a peaceful
Democratic demonstration you know you
need seizure resistance in this world
especially
so I would argue that gold was a good
proxy for power because it required
power to obtain the purchasing power
sword they're in right it's skin in the
game it's symmetry
um
and you can't counterfeit energy this is
very key right if you want a money that
can't be counterfeited well then rooted
in the thing no one knows how to
counterfeit which is the thermodynamic
physical reality of energy itself cannot
be created nor destroyed cannot produce
it without work
um and so the nation state
historically
is the most politically powerful
institution in the world but I would
argue it's only because they hold the
most physically power relevant tool
which was gold right the state that
accumulated the most gold became the
dominant state in the world
so
a little bit more on gold and then we
can move on as I said earlier the
physicality is kind of a double-edged
sword right so the physicality of gold
as we're talking about when the Walmart
the guards were securing the cash at
Walmart right there's physical cash that
requires physical security to protect it
from theft or seizure from others
so in a physics sense
the physicality of gold makes it a good
proxy for power if that's how we're
defining gold in the sense that you have
to expend energy to earn the energy that
gold represents
but I would say in a political sense and
I'm going to Define this more shortly
Gold's bad because it incentivizes
incentivizes the centralization of gold
into one location and
I think that's because Gold's just not
portable right we need money to be
movable it needs to be transactable it's
much better if I can beam money around
the world at the speed of light than it
is load a bunch of gold bars on a
container ship and wait three months
right if we're going to increase the
division of labor we need fast money
um so another definition I've given is
money's a tool for moving value across
space and time gold was good at time but
not space currency is good at space but
because we break it from gold it doesn't
hold value over time that's why dollars
are a terrible store of value yes and as
we'll talk about a little bit later you
know Bitcoin perfects both of these
effectively
so
the lack of Gold's portability led to
the creation of this derivative
application called currency
but then when you break with that
application you have to trust someone to
maintain the peg to Gold otherwise you
and you radically empower the currency
issuer if they can just start producing
currency with no check meaning citizens
have no option to redeem that currency
for gold then the issuing institution
which is the central bank will grow and
grow and grow until it pathologizes the
whole world
that's what's going on in the world
today in my estimation
when you think
through the ramifications of that so
that's what's happening what is like the
biggest ramification that you identify
okay guys you might think that okay X
sounds like a new genius football
formation it's actually not Charlie it's
your new favorite crypto trading app
you heard the man
[Music]
well I think it is and again the next
thing I want to do is Define political
power which sort of rounds out the other
side of this
so far we basically said that physical
power is the essence of being alive and
everything we're doing in the world but
to maximize our physical power footprint
in the world to harness more energy and
channel it across time we need these
symbolic structures right we're the
animal that plays imaginary
acting and concert enables us to move a
lot more matter than we could in
isolation as you described with your
example earlier
so but the symbolic structures
themselves if they're just stories
they can be they're subject to political
power
and so I want to Define political power
as something born from the faith humans
have in that symbolic structure
and the roles that individuals play
inside of it
so when you go into a meeting with I
don't know a representative of a
sovereign wealth fund
right he's just a guy playing a role
inside of a symbolic structure that has
authority over certain assets that may
or may not invest in whatever project
you're there to talk to him about for
instance
so this
but that gives the individual a lot of
power you know political power that they
can start to again follow their own
incentives rather than following the
laws
and bend things in a way that benefit
them perhaps at the expense of other
participants in the symbolic structure
because often there's an information
asymmetry right an individual an Insider
may know certain things that Outsiders
do not and they can use that information
to Arbitrage and other activities to
profit for themselves at the expense of
others which again the central bank I
would say that's exclusively what
they're doing correct right it's a
monopoly on currency production to
externalize the costs privatize the
profit
so
and again you know
so political power exists everywhere
that it basically uh everywhere that
we're being human it exists to at least
some extent it doesn't matter again if
it's your company right you've got
company politics surely you also have
state politics
um country politics all these things but
the symbolic structures and the power
anyone has over you inside of them
results from the collective imagination
right like you
you could always quit your job you can
always start a new company you you can
always opt out of these things so it's
not a real physical power that the
president has over 330 million Apes in
the United States it's all premised on
this symbolic structure which has a
political Dimension to it as a result of
us just being human
so
apology said this yesterday it's like we
have to LARP these things into existence
LARP being the acronym for Live Action
role-playing
and it really seems like that's what
we're doing we have to kind of pretend
fake it till you make it pretend these
realities into existence but then the we
kind of start to forget you know like we
just think it's real like we think the
United States is some permanent fixture
of reality or any other country or any
other company whatever maybe not
companies so much
and we forget that we just it's just
play it's just imaginal serious play
that we're engaged in
and so a couple of these ideas that
we've created that have been
tremendously important we've already
alluded to this earlier
the idea of the individual actually this
is one we take so for granted it sounds
funny for me to even say yes but
pre-christ
the idea of the individual was not
really that strong it was about uh they
called it the paternal families I think
I'm pronouncing it right the family
right that you were just a component of
the family typically it was related to a
very distinct geographical plot of land
they used to have
um like a fire they would maintain in
the Hearth and they would always keep
the fire alive and if they ever had to
move they would move the fire and it was
symbolic of their ancestors so the idea
of like the individual much less a
sovereign individual didn't exist in our
symbolic structure pre-christ
and without and for all I won't go into
this topic there's a great book called
inventing the individual in inventing
the individual where I got this and I
would just encourage people to check it
out
with no idea of the individual you
cannot have an idea of private property
obviously it doesn't make sense that an
individual can have an exclusive
relationship to assets if you don't have
the idea of the individual in the first
place
so
that I mean it just shows you like you
said earlier this this Segway Of You
Know Christianity leading to the
founding the United States and then
private property and then economic
success stories like faying stocks you
would not think that Facebook Apple
Netflix Amazon Google are related to
Christ that much but when you understand
how integral property is to the process
of civilization I think you can draw
this through line
and so like to that end the U.S
Constitution in terms of symbolic
structures it's been one of the most
successful that we've ever created
and it was you know we're set up as a
decentralized republic with checks and
balances built in and again built on
this Christian notion of honoring the
sovereignty of the individual
so it's just it's tremendous how in some
way the Constitution is the code base
yeah right it is the Constitution is uh
kind of that initial code base and uh
there are amendments right that there
are changes there are additions uh
whatever
um and uh in some way also there is uh
the ability to propose changes uh there
has to be discussion uh and eventually
there has to be a process as to which uh
to reach agreement on those amendments
or changes uh but it is very similar to
the creation of software uh both in in
kind of the initial Inception but also
in the upgrading yes of that uh document
those ideas uh and at the end of the day
those words and language yes uh for a
society and it is it's distributed
cognitive software that we're writing
rewriting you know stories we're
building we're inserting ourselves into
taking ourselves out of I would take it
a step further and say the way you
describe the Constitution it sounds a
lot like the way the Bible was written
actually right there's a long process a
lot of people a lot of amendments
rejections changes Etc
that's almost like the moral code base
or a moral code base not the amoral code
base and then the US Constitution was
like the legal ratification of that
moral code base into something political
yeah I think the dictionary a lot too
like there's a movie uh I think it's
like uh a genius and a Madman or
something and uh you forget that like
somebody sat down I was like we are
going to write a list of every word yes
and what what the definition is right I
said that was like the idea for the
dictionary uh and
um
it is a database of words and those
words actually end up getting debated uh
and we have seen in recent times some of
the definitions have changed some of
those definitions have been upgraded
some people would argue that they
actually are being changed for political
reasons right whatever
but it's a database of words that goes
through these processes and what's
fascinating is that if a language is
derived from all of us
there's like this one little group of
people Merriam-Webster right as one
example who gets to decide what is in
their list of words right
is that a collective decision or is that
have we outsourced
words and definitions to an organization
right yeah it's kind of the C A
centralizing effect on that open source
software we call English
and it's man it's such a good point
because
when you consider that every the word is
almost like the elementary particle of
the symbolic structure right
obviously like you need language to be a
human to create these things
but my understanding of a word and your
understanding of a word like the degree
to which language is useful is that the
degree to which our understanding aligns
on those words but I obviously don't
right you've lived a different life
you've had a different experience as
have I you've heard the word used in
different contexts as of I now in a very
common word like V it's probably pretty
sharp our consensus on that word but on
some more abstract term it might be a
little more deviated so this whole thing
is like we're constantly
engaging in dialogue to try and reach
consensus on the meaning of words and
then use those words to create these
stories that we live in and
Integrity is key
the thing needs to mean the same thing
over time so to the extent I don't know
about this but to the extent Webster or
whatever political institution or
symbolic structure is changing the
definitions of words and where the word
recession came up for me there or I know
recession uh uh the uh the male female
well also uh things like the CDC uh
expanded the definition of vaccine these
types of things but also uh what is even
fascinating is it doesn't have to be
maybe uh what I would say are the most
controversial or debatable where people
get uh into the culturals and things
like that the idea of political parties
Republican and Democrat over the years
the stance on certain topics or the
ideological uh kind of position of those
political parties has changed
drastically sometimes changes and then
changes back like a 180. but but the
word uh Republican or Democrat the
definition has natural really changed
and
what's most interesting about it is that
the definition from a objective
standpoint may not change
but from a uh kind of understanding
through Society changes because the
ideological ideological position isn't
necessarily on every single topic
written to the definition of what is
Republican what is Democrat right 100
yeah yes that's it's kind of like Theory
versus uh reality yeah right and and I
think that's what you see with a lot of
uh of these Concepts and I think that's
why aspiring dictators seek well
historically seek to control the media
and control the money right these are
two very important symbolic structures
for for allocating and moving
information
so
so the US Constitution is one of the
most useful symbolic structures we've
created to date and this I would say
that's true because the problem the very
pragmatic problem humans have been
trying to solve for a long time is like
how do we preserve the relationship
between us and our stuff as we've said
property right that's the exclusive
purpose of government I know it's grown
a lot and expanded beyond the scope of
that originally but that is really all
we need it to do the market can do
everything else
the other way to say that is like back
to the world of power how do we preserve
the extension of the individual Will To
Power into the world so that if the
entrepreneur goes into the world and
engages all his Ingenuity and faculties
to create something other people value
we don't want other people to come and
steal that from him because in that
disincentivizes entrepreneurship and
leads to destivilization
so we need a security provider as we
said to to enshrine and defend that that
idea of property
and in that way the property property is
and I talk about this on blue in the
face of my show but I really think I
agree with Ayn Rand property is the
basis of civilization it's the there are
no other human rights possible without
property if you can't preserve the
fruits of your labor across time there's
nothing else beyond that
um and so
it's it's also the source of all this
political Strife because the state
exists to preserve property and it is
also preying on property through
taxation and inflation
so as you know there's a great quote by
klauschwitz he's an old German
philosopher in Warfare he says war is
just the continuation of policy or
politics by other means
so it's that it's fighting over stuff
that's all we're trying to solve for
here honestly it may sound like an
oversimplification but I don't see where
there's anything else there yeah the
idea also of uh war ends up being uh
the point at which some portion of the
population intersects policy
so if you were looking at the United
States 330 million people or so
how many of those people could tell you
what the policies of the United States
are outside of laws
what is our stance from an economic
perspective what is our stance on a
geopolitical perspective what is our
stance on climate uh change or on energy
or uh in uh ecological uh preservation
or you know all these different you can
go really really deep in the rabbit hole
you can start with the really high ideas
most people have no [ __ ] clue I go to
work every day I do the best to do a
good job there I get paid and take care
of my family and like leave me alone
right
but when a country engages in war that
is the point at which it becomes uh
policy has risen to the severity uh and
uh conversation level that now everyone
for the most part is aware of it right
not 100 but 90 plus percent of people
and so in some way whether they agree or
not with the policy if your nation is at
War you will be asked to participate
directly or indirectly oh yeah and that
is like a very interesting uh way to
back into like politics don't matter
don't pay attention all that
until you get to the extremes and then
all of a sudden it's the only thing that
may matter for an individual yeah I'm
reminded of that quote you may not be
interested in war but war is interested
in you yes right again when the physical
the situation of physical power comes to
the foreground right whether it's
Hurricane Katrina or it's World War II
all of the sudden everyone in that
symbolic structure is oriented One
Direction right it's towards that in
some way
so
the danger all right again we said this
earlier the danger of these things is
that they're they're stories so they can
be corrupted and I want to try and
Define Corruption here
I would Define Corruption as
participants inside of a symbolic
structure that understand
the rules and expectations to be one
thing right there's consensus on the
rules
consent of the governed as we say in the
U.S
um
if an individual operating in a position
of authority inside that symbolic
structure will now Bend or twist those
rules
for private gain and uh that does not
apply to the public typically it costs
the public because they're often
extracting resources that the public has
generated through the market process
that is corruption right so bending a
rule for private gain
um
I'm sorry being a public rule for
private gain I would Define as
corruption and this is like that phrase
that we've heard recently rules for thee
not for me right that is that's
corruption in a nutshell
so
again symbolic structures and this is
could be social institution hierarchy
story whatever you want to call it
necessary for us to live at the top of
the food chain but given the Ethereal
nature of these things they're not real
right
that we can they can be twisted in the
imaginations of people and the image the
imaginations of inhabitants by others
right you can tell a new story or a
competing story this is often called
narratives too right like information
Warfare narrative Warfare
and this is the domain of propagandists
rhetoricians bullshitters right they're
trying to feed you some false symbolic
reality to get you to do something that
they want you to do they're trying to
binge you to their will effectively and
so
that is corruption in a nutshell and we
know corruption precedes
self-destruction right have you ever had
a corrupted hard drive
have you ever seen the end game of a
corrupt government uh look what happened
to Enron right they bent this reality of
public accountability for private gain
and vaporized 70 billion dollars of
wealth in the process right corruption
is like it's pathology it's destruction
it's disease and so the more we can
prevent public rules from being bent
twisted or broken
to the end of private gain the less
corruptable the symbolic structure
becomes the better off we all are yes
and so what we really need what humans
need is an Incorruptible which I think
is the equivalent to seeing an
indestructible symbolic structure
because if you can't corrupt the story
then you can't destroy the story I mean
at least I know this is a bit abstract
but
seems about the same thing to me
and so we need a story to inhabit that
cannot be Rewritten by the winner right
by by the most violent you need an
actual
um
story hopefully based on something like
principles right truth justice Freedom
all these things that we all want and
seek we have a natural inclination
towards we want that integrated into the
symbolic structure that we inhabit
and so you know if it's Justice what to
just keep what you earn or get what you
deserve that's what the justice system
is right and that's what our natural
idea of justice is just people getting
what they deserve so we've all this is
not something new we've been attempting
to do this for a long time
uh I think hopefully I'm just throwing
light on in kind of a new way but
so
in that world where people get what they
deserve I think that's
similar to saying we have a world where
property is unbreakable or inviable so
people
what they work to create they keep
and what is stolen is returned right
like that's the kind of the general
themes of Justice we would like to see
in socioeconomic reality
it's where the relationship between
people and their assets is a
non-revocable relationship and that
would make all trade consensual right
because you wouldn't in that world where
you can't steal people's stuff I always
say this on the show too there's two
Avenues to wealth acquisition there's
making and there's taking
to the extent that you cannot engage in
taking if I can't take stuff from people
I'm left with no other option than to go
to work right make something trade with
people
so the game we've been playing is trying
to reduce the incentives toward taking
in our symbolic structure so we can tilt
people towards making
if we had something like that there was
like actual invaluable property an
indestructible symbolic structure that
would maximally amplify the individual
Will To Power all of a sudden people
would be able to go out and to the best
of their abilities create what they want
for themselves in the world with the the
limiting principle of other people's
Will To Power right you can't tread on
other people to take their stuff so
everyone's almost they're Sovereign
right this is the sovereign individual
idea
and it's
I would say that indestructible symbolic
structure like that is absolutely
necessary to maximize human Freedom we
have to have a symbolic structure to the
extent that it's not corruptable it
lasts longer over time it produces more
wealth it creates more satisfaction if
you want it increases the carrying
capacity of the planet for God's sakes
so like if you if you are if you have a
Will To Power which you do if you're
alive and listening to this you would
want this as a thing
and again I think that's what the U.S
was an attempt at right we tried to
create this decentralized less
corruptable governance mechanism with
checks and balances intrinsic to it such
it would resist corruption
but I think also that is what Bitcoin is
Bitcoin has
it's the closest thing to an
indestructible symbolic structure we've
ever had yeah I agree with that these
are rules that cannot be twisted or
broken for private gain it's essentially
and it's paradoxical in a lot of ways
but it's essentially this public utility
used to facilitate the transfer of
private property like two things we
never thought we could get into one
bucket we somehow have
rules that can't be changed it's based
on a purely opt-in opt-out social
consensus
nothing there's no coercion in it
whatsoever there's nothing hidden right
there's no there's not even the
opportunity for information asymmetry
because it's open source technology
so towards this idea which we've been
working I think Bitcoin is the greatest
reach yet
when you think of the rules not rulers
right idea
um it does feel like uh the
financialization of this software uh in
some way imagine if uh the Constitution
had a stock you know price or ticker
price uh attached to it and people could
trade it people may not put as much uh
importance on uh the Constitution's
words the ideas like all of these other
components that we find so valuable it
The Birth of a Nation the the kind of
North Star if you will
if you are able which is hard for humans
if you're able to look past uh the
volatility in an exchange price and you
are simply to evaluate the system based
on the technology uh the ethos and and
the idea
it is
I would venture to say probably the only
piece of technology that we have which
provides rules without rulers which
allows for uh um this coordination on a
global scale
with the ability for people to opt in or
out
and as you said cannot be used
for corrupt purposes in the sense of uh
the people that are actually using the
system uh as uh people of positions of
power and influence so I think one of
the other things is when you hear rules
without rulers there's a difference
between the ruler right having a
government with a monopoly on violence
or whatever political power stuff right
the president or prime minister or
whatever
that doesn't mean that there aren't
people that have positions of influence
or power
a single Mining Node right or a single
uh uh Asic that has a position now it
may be a very small position of power
influence in this larger network but it
is still a position as they see it at
the table in that specific consensus
mechanism part of the of the the system
also individuals who simply just hold
the asset have a position of power and
influence it may again be very small in
the grand scheme of things but it is a
position and so in some way it is rules
without rulers but there are still
people who are involved in this process
because it goes back to this part of
like the people make up the society the
people make up a kind of civilization
the people end up making up the network
as well now they may choose to exhibit
their participation via uh buying and
holding some people want to do a trading
so people want to do it spending but
also they may say and actually I want to
coordinate resources to buy machines to
secure the network or or maybe I want to
create content around it or whatever it
is but it's still at the end of the day
people participating on an individual
level and that's what ultimately makes
up this huge network but it doesn't
allow anyone to rise to the position of
ruler which is one of if not the
greatest Advantage the system provides
absolutely this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eight sleep pod is the
best sleep machine I sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep yeah we were
talking about I mean Bitcoin is a global
decentralized organization it's the
first of its kind right so it's a
leaderless CEO less organization and it
has a gigantic market cap it's been
stunningly successful in what it set out
to do
and
to your point it the individuals inside
of that Network
are maximally sovereign or individually
empowered with their Will To Power is
being honored such that they don't
suffer Kings right there's not there's
not an opportunity for political
authorities to rise to power as much in
a bitcoinized world because citizens can
always vote with their wallet or vote
with their feet if you're not treating
me well in a certain jurisdiction I can
take my capital and leave very easily
which is you know obviously in countries
today a lot of that's inhibited through
Capital controls and all kinds of other
bureaucratic imaginations so all we're
talking about here is
increasing the individual Will To Power
holds the symbolic structure of
government in check right it it makes it
accountable to its p l and therefore
accountable to its customers which are
citizens
that I would say is kind of the core
problem we have on the Fiat standard is
that government doesn't care about its p
l because it can paper over all of its
losses by printing new money that's why
we get all these Antiquated government
organizations that never go away and if
you're not accountable to your p l as an
organization why do you care about the
preferences of your customers you can
just steal from your customers so that
like this is the problem this is the
human problem right now is that we have
this the dominant symbolic structure in
the world
extracts from us and we don't have a way
to cast
well pre-bitcoin we did not have a way
to cast a credible vote of no confidence
and say this doesn't work for me Uncle
Sam I'm gonna do something different and
Bitcoin is an emergent alternative to
the whole game right it's
it's like the first Level Playing Field
we've ever had or the first true you
know
Equitable story whatever you want to
call it I almost think uh in some crazy
way if you've ever played uh backyard
football or Street uh uh football uh and
let's say it was in a neighborhood as a
kid and you showed up and you kind of
sort of knew the kids they lived in the
neighborhood or in the general area uh
and you're playing a game and you pretty
much knew almost immediately like hey
this is a game where uh the rules are
very well defined or like oh you stepped
out of bounds where's that about uh it's
like kind of like lined up here you know
and you would very quickly be able to
tell like oh these people are going to
bend the rules however to try to gain an
advantage in the game
in many cases although yes we do have
the rules written down we have seen uh
those rules changed in what I'll call
the Legacy world and so that can be uh
around taxation that can be around
monetary policy it could be around uh
fiscal policy and that can be around a
whole bunch of other aspects
it is not to argue that they don't have
the power to change the rules they do uh
it is not to argue even sometimes that
the rule changes aren't positive
sometimes they are positive but it is
just that the rules can change
unilaterally uh based on those in power
yes and there's unpredictability the
difference is
if you showed up to play that backyard
football and they had basically a
granite you know tablet and they had
chiseled the rules in and it said these
are the rules if you play the game these
are the rules we played yes
and now there is no debate yes it is
there are the rules and no one's gonna
walk over even with a uh uh a racer and
a marker and oh let me erase rule number
three and write a different way it is
they are literally chiseled into granite
that is two different environments and
that's I think ultimately what we're
talking about is this like analogous
situation where uh you cannot change the
monetary policy right and it does not
matter how many people you get that want
to do that because there have been
people who have wanted to change whether
it's monetary policy technical uh uh
components whatever
and they have even been able to Loosely
coordinate with more than 50 percent of
the hash rate in the miners
still cannot do it right and this idea
which I don't haven't heard a lot of
people explore is that in the United
States government which I think most
people would look at and point say this
is a democratic government uh and it's
the best that we've seen so far
can somebody come with a better solution
maybe I don't know what's going to
happen in the future but right now this
seems to be the best way of governance
uh that the world has ever seen
with three branches of government and
those three branches of government
provide checks and balances on each
other in the Bitcoin ecosystem we also
have three branches you have the
developers you have the nodes and you
have the miners
and those three branches of Bitcoin end
up providing checks and balances on each
other
and so
when you compare those two things
I don't know if people can argue that
there is a better way to actually
protect the rules of economic trade
right then what we already know is the
best way system of governance we've ever
created we simply are now just copying
and pasting it via software and
Technology yes for this new system yeah
yeah it's it's an upgrade of what the US
cons the spirit of the US Constitution
lives in Bitcoin yes right and that the
the idea of the rules chiseled in
Granite the immutable rule set I would
argue that is the Bedrock of peaceful
gameplay yes I've talked about this a
lot right if you sit down to play poker
and the hand rankings or rules change
every few hands you're just gonna go
nuts right you can't play the game how
how can you form a a productive strategy
when the rules are changing all the time
there's too much unpredictability in the
system so that's all we're saying with
Bitcoin it's like just give us a Level
Playing Field and let people play the
game of the market process and let's
just create as much wealth as possible
to solve as many problems as possible
and the further point to it is that
when they're immutable and changeless
and open and transparent it's all opt-in
right no one's forcing you to use
Bitcoin
and the episode I did with Jordan
Peterson he talked about this that it's
kind of obvious kids only like to play
games that are voluntary as soon as you
try to go and play a game with girls
like here are the new rules like okay
bully we're gonna go over here and play
right so there's this natural
inclination to organize around the rules
that are voluntary open clear changeless
and kids do it like how about we start
doing it as adults right we actually
learn something from kids in this
respect so
to try to bring this thing full circle
as we said at the beginning money is a
proxy for power
and I decompose power into physical and
a political sense
um
and I think Bitcoin is the best proxy
for power we've ever had
in that it's a story that can't be
Rewritten by those that wield violence
right this is very important it's a
story that can't be Rewritten by the
winners
uh it's a property relationship so
again relationship between owner and
asset that's
virtually independent of the Monopoly on
violence like if you hold your private
keys
in a proper custody schema and I always
recommend multi-signature
distributed geographically
you you're very independent or isolated
from the political apparatus there's no
law passing that can change anything
there's no confiscation or inflation
that's going to affect you
and it's an incentive structure it's a
brand new symbolic structure that has
very strong incentives that tilts all of
humanity away from Warfare and towards
peace and this is like probably the most
beautiful promise of the whole thing
and
it's a good proxy for power in my
opinion because it's rooted in physical
power through proof of work you have to
spend energy to gain the purchasing
power stored therein
and it's also so that like it's like
gold in that respect but unlike gold
it's resistant more resistant to
political power because it's
dematerialized to use sailor's awesome
word
and it's it's has this uh I would even
say the Satoshi creation myth as part of
this as well right it's it's a
foundational to that symbolic structure
uh to the idea of decentralization
that's encoded into Bitcoin and it's the
reason these other projects can't seem
to achieve decentralization right they
can't get the magic of that in a bottle
not to say that it's not possible but
it's proven to be damn hard so far
and so I'm
on the Satoshi creation myth I'm
reminded of that movie Batman Begins
where Bruce is coming back from his
training and
um wherever he was in the mountains and
he's on the plane I think he's with
Alfred and he says
as a man I'm flushed in blood I can be
ignored I can be destroyed but as a
symbol as a symbol I can be
Incorruptible I can be Everlasting so
when Satoshi vanished like he took
Bitcoin from some project that a guy
started to this symbolic structure with
no individual right to attack or
denigrate or anything like this so he
transcended like Satoshi is now just a
symbol all right we don't know who he is
he's just symbolic and he's like the
godhead of this mythological structure
we've created in Bitcoin
and so
I think Bitcoin is a fundamental
reimagining of human civilization right
we have a perfect proxy for power if you
will something that optimizes the
individual Will To Power and is bounded
by the will to power of others so my
interests stop where yours begin right
we can all push up against each other
but it's only through consensual
Exchange in a Bitcoin eyes world that we
are productive the taking strategy for
wealth acquisition is less profitable
than the making strategy
its Integrity is rooted in the law laws
of physics as we've already said with
proof of work and it's resistant to
politics because it's dematerialized
so I think that's it Bitcoin optimizes
our ability to express our Will To Power
and therefore lets us be free
I'll leave you with one last part of
this idea that I think is really
important
you can't kill an idea
that's right which is a saying that I
think as people understand a lot about
history they realize many of these ideas
have been passed down
but there was a bifurcation of History
ideas used to be passed down exclusively
By Word of Mouth I would tell you
something you would tell somebody who
would tell somebody who would tell
somebody and eventually their kids and
their grandkids and their great
grandkids and it would get passed all
the way down the lineage and it was all
Word of Mouth
and at some point somebody figured out
we should write it down
and writing it down meant that that
piece of paper had to survive and there
was great care that was uh put to have
that piece of paper survive and then the
idea of well maybe we should multiply it
so that if one gets destroyed the idea
is available in other places and so you
get kind of the this uh history of how
ideas got from inception all the way
down to modern day
Bitcoin is the exact same thing there is
this idea of decentralization of uh
being able to create rules not rulers
being able to build a system for
economic trade on a global scale that is
dematerialized that uses economic uh uh
kind of value protected by energy
it's an idea somebody wrote it down
in code
and then that code was able to Garner
enough attention
where it is protected to some degree
but it also was then multiplied and sits
on every single node yes and so if one
copy gets destroyed it still lives on
and so one of the key ideas that I think
is really hard for people to wrap their
heads around
a company is an idea a building is an
idea
the idea of a company or the idea of a
building can actually not be killed
people will always know what a company
is they will always know what a building
is
a specific company
the idea of Enron still lives on but
that company is dead and so there's this
separation between the idea and the
asset
with Bitcoin what is unique is that
unless you were able to convince every
single Miner every single node and every
single holder to essentially walk away
through coercion force or whatever
the idea will never go away but the
asset will not either
because of the multiplication effect yes
it's like having taking a a idea put it
into books and then have created
millions and millions and millions of
copies yes you can burn
half a million a million five million 10
million 20 500 million yes you can't
burn them all right and I think that
that ends up being this kind of Hydra
life uh uh kind of concept that once
People wrap their heads around it it
gives you a very different perspective
as to what the future will look like
specifically related to a concept like
this I love that it's the anti-fragility
of an idea right of these symbolic
structures and it's to your point rooted
in that technological reality of copying
right when we create the printing press
and all of a sudden the cost of book
production collapses
you can burn as many bibles as you want
the Bible as an idea is not going
anywhere right it's totally
decentralized it's here it's here to
stay basically there are people who can
recite it without even reading it right
right
and so Bitcoin is again just taken that
principle a step further right it's it's
replicated in so many different places
constantly all the time that it makes it
very
close to indestructible or definitely
anti-fragile at least
and so it's
phenomenal you know and it's interesting
how much again if we're just ideas we're
just genetic information we're
imprinting these ideas into the world
through various substrates right whether
it's paper or digital
and then that somehow feeds back into us
like we're engaging this co-evolutionary
process that we call civilization
and so
it you know there's a there's a moral
imperative here it's ethical it's
technological it's pragmatic it's
Financial
and you know I just hope that all this
talking we're doing about Bitcoin is
helping nudge the world in the right
direction
the
the concept of Bitcoin
has a lot of surface area because the
financial asset is technology solution
uh as an ethos so all these different
things
what I find so powerful for
it is you can take a single idea which
is the Bitcoin system
and if it only had one surface area it
would not be nearly as valuable because
in some way Bitcoin is different for
everyone what what is the value to you
if you are fleeing a country the idea
that you can now move your assets
without having a confiscated is pretty
damn important
you don't care about volatility you
don't care about uh cheap fees or any of
this other thing you just want the
ability to have sovereignty yes there
are other people who say all of my
assets are completely Sovereign I go to
the bank I can do all these different
things the sovereignty aspect of it is
not very important to my day-to-day life
but I send a lot of money back home to
my family in another country and so the
ability to do that very cheaply and
quickly is important to me and so when
you have that what it does is it also
opens the surface area of the
addressable Market
[Music]
and if you really look at it money may
be the only thing that has an
addressable Market that matches
the number of humans on earth right I'm
not sure
that
there is another technology the internet
probably would be the one other
technology that people would point to
there are plenty of people's language
right language right yeah I guess
there's another one yeah but but there's
not many of them and everyone speaks
everyone transacts not everyone uses the
internet right right right
um and so it's like this very weird
thing where we're headed towards a world
where
these assets that you and I and kind of
think through and and talk about
the person who
adopts them or or or is interested in
them 10 years from now they're not going
to care so much about some of these
underlying elements so I think a lot
about uh sequence
ten years ago the technical components
of Bitcoin were really [ __ ] important
because you needed to uh attract a
certain type of uh individual who could
then help to propel Bitcoin forward for
the next three four five years
but we've gone through some of these
regime shifts
the technical components obviously still
matter for Bitcoin in terms of the
security and the decentralization
but not a lot of people or the majority
of people are not showing up now being
like you know what I love about Bitcoin
I love the uh difficulty adjustment and
and the beauty like right that's not the
mainstream group of people who are
showing up now
but a lot of them are showing up and
saying hey the fact that uh with the
backdrop of undisciplined monetary and
fiscal policy that no one can
unilaterally change that that's really
important to me which is corruption
again I just want to emphasize monetary
and fiscal policy are both corruption
and so when you then fast forward five
years from now I don't know what it will
be at the time but there will be
something else that then is attracting
people to the idea and to me that's the
beauty of this is that it's constantly
evolving it's beautiful indeed and uh
indispensable in the current macro
backdrop of the world where we're
actively witnessing
Legacy symbolic structures collapse
around us right Rome is burning
and so there will come a point where
people may think they don't need the
sovereignty aspect of Bitcoin because
they trust their bank and they trust
their brokerage account and clear
whatever
there could come a point where that
trust is diminished significantly to
where they will seek shelter in an
indestructible symbolic structure like
Bitcoin and so I you know not only is it
as we said indispensable to human
freedom but as the other ones collapse
there's going to be this like osmotic
pressure I think that forces people into
and I think this is where a lot of
detractors just don't get it they think
it's some arbitrary Choice like do I
choose dollars do I choose boulevards
you know it doesn't matter why would I
choose Bitcoin it's like this is why
because all of the other structures are
being corrupted and breaking down and so
people will naturally
you know in expressing their Will To
Power they will seek shelter in the one
that is resistant to corruption and
destruction without a doubt where can we
send people to find you on the internet
if uh if they would like more ideas from
your brain
uh I'm on Twitter at breedlove22
brve22 I've got a sub stack and then you
can check out the what is money show
what is moneypodcast.com we're on RSS
feed and YouTube and thank you so much
for having me as always I we could do
this literally every day and I don't
think we'd run out of things to talk
about so I appreciate you coming and I
will definitely do it again thanks man